we would like to now introduce a new
methodological tool for analyzing
problems that involve momentum transfers
and we call that tool momentum diagrams
now what we'd like to do is look at our
fundamental idea which was for discrete
objects we have that involved in a
collision we have that the external
force integrated with respect to time
impulse is equal to the change in
momentum between two different states so
this is the momentum of the final state
and this is the momentum of the initial
state so when we want to analyze
problems how can we methodologically
introduce a picture representation of
our problems so let's look at what we
need to do first we always need to
choose a system that we're referring to
and with respect to the choice of that
system we need to also choose a
reference frame now once we've done that
we can now represent a collision with
respect to this system for instance
let's consider two objects as our system
object one and object two they're moving
on a frictionless horizontal surface and
we're choosing as a reference frame the
ground frame now what we'd like to do is
identify two states so for our initial
State we'll have if we're given some
initial conditions what we'd like to do
is represent each object with a velocity
vector so here we'll write v1 initial
and let's suppose this object is coming
at it with v2 initial as an example
and once we've represented the
velocities of the objects we can write
down their momentum in the initial State
similarly if these two objects collide
and they're moving we actually don't
know which way those objects will end up
moving and so what we'd again like to do
in our final
State after this collision is to
represent the velocities by again
vectors so this is v1 final and this is
the two final and then we can represent
the change in momentum so our momentum
principle now becomes in this case let's
just assume that the external force here
sums to zero we're assuming no friction
and then our momentum principle says
that zero equals P final minus P initial
and now we can read off those Momentum's
as vectors on the diagram and so what we
have is that the final momentum will be
equal to the initial momentum so we can
write down M 1 final plus M 2 B 2 final
is equal to M 1 V 1 initial plus M two V
two initial and that's how we can
represent a collision where there's no
external forces and use our momentum
principle to get an a vector equation
now in many problems you're given
information you might be given
information about the speeds and
magnitudes of the objects and in order
to then take this equation and represent
it in speeds and directions or even
components we need to choose some
coordinate system so if we choose a
coordinate system and that's the third
step so suppose we choose a coordinate
system then we can start to look at two
different representations for our
problem for instance let's just choose
this to be the I hat direction
now given that choice we could describe
the velocities in terms of components
now this is gets awkward b1i
x component i hat and similarly we can
write down all the velocities v2i
as the 2i X I hat etc for all the
velocities and our momentum equation in
components then becomes in the I hat
direction m1 v1 I X plus well here we
have the final state so let's make this
consistent the final plus m2v2
final x equals m1 v1 initial x plus m2
v2 initial X and that's the same
equation that we have as vectors now
expressed in terms of components and
recall that components can be positive
or negative